si vous connaissez
le
sans raison ici que se joue donc je suis
rappelé de d'un parcours sans fin mai
chez lui ce que je veux maintenant aller
chez d'autres c'est très simple c'est
que aujourd'hui ce que je suis devenu si
jamais vous étiez comme ça moi
cosmétiques
mon rêve c'est de venir pas trop joué à
la batterie j'ai compris si t'es pas
c'est qu'on réussisse et c'est parce que
je sais faire
ce que je voudrais c'est que j'ai
commencé j'ai commencé très jeune
j'étais je suivais dans la solitude vite
et toujours main le petit garçon lisse
mais fait j'ai su non plus important que
vous connaître vous pas faire les choses
à régler et je sais que c'était ici ce
qu'on n'a pas fait une seule chose pour
arriver ici il vous parle je vous allez
sans un jeu que ce soit même une force
régionale ce soir et c'est pourquoi nous
les jeux ont conseillé d'en informer les
jours tu pour celui qu'est ce que tu
fais ta vie tu te dis moi je suis mon
domaine c'est le journal il faut pas les
stars sont les jeunes notre d'anglais
c'est le monde entier n'a qu on peut
faire plein de choses devant la seule
chose que je m'en doutais ces gens-là
nier la ccl animations bateau et à
partager bien non ça c'est certain
dans la tour en huit ans et un jour très
spécial
donc effectivement j'ai composé d'un
cinéma rejet je viens par ici à paris en
france du fait des études de cinéma j p
si moi de voir
des infirmières pour faire plaisir à
musique hyper léger ou du cinéma
j'ai commencé production ménages je suis
au jeu via quelques courts métrages
intéressé par deux mille ans s'appelle
pays
après j'ai déjà vu ma et la sortie ce
film attire l'attention
je laisse mon avis le directeur le
patron de la plus haute qualité chez lui
par la radio dans son bureau
et si lui jeudi parce que c'est c'est
lui c'est la personne qui m'a motivé de
faire quelque chose rare parce qu'on
avait nos pièces qui semblent conduire
en france on allait tous c'est l'idée de
la marquise rien faire selon le site à
part pas et c'était avant gilles à élire
avec le sida et à faire pas mal de
choses donc il m'a demandé de participer
aux sessions et je participe
ça va aussi parce qu'il est parti ce
festival est à ses dernières éditions
par un concile
j'ai les leviers réalisation et c'est là
où ça va motiver ses abjean eu à cause
toujours tu y es comédie ce vieux
l'amour pour le journalier et pour la
presse en général mais ce qui m'inquiète
plus consommée c'est la relation de us
si vous suivez les derniers mois
inquiète je suis très concentré sur
l'asie
le message important
moi je dis je pouvais pas changer le
monde d'être sensibilisé le changement
le changement à montréal et c'est vrai
que comme il agit d'elliot à g la ville
saint georges est rien je le dis si tu
es salam en juin je veux dire aussi un
très bon salaire chaussée et a aidé par
semaine et j'avais lui la situation
s'est dit super g toute l'année pour
faire ce projet qui s'appelle moins que
le cours du pétrole
vous allez demander pourquoi zemmour
dérape c'est très simple lorsque vous
début j'avais j'avais vidé je pensais
pas le faire mais je vous ai tous mes
amis sont déjà engagés vous avez
simplement je dois faire nous ont dit
voilà je commence à me poser
finances etc et sa femme a mis mal à
l'aise c'est vraiment dommage je sais
pas faire ça donc je me suis dit plus
que moi je suis chase et on l'a donc
tout ce qui est en relation avec la
touche humaine c'est que j'ai pris la
décision pour savoir que c'est pas mal
fabrice bien parce qu'il ya des gens qui
il ya dix ans déjà du maroc - du pays
les jeunes y compris battre que mais
sait on ne veut pas d'un commencé il n'y
a pas dans le détail
donc je suis lancé on le sucre but
d'avoir des réponses à des questions qui
restaient au moins un peu noirci quand
j'étais en france on est payé ans ne
s'était pas déplacé
tresquois etc
c'est que on se posait des questions que
les gens aient posé la question ghz et
pourquoi dès fier d'être mince que
j'entendais sénégal n'avait pas de
réponse mais je suis parti voir la
matière pour avoir message ce que je
fais c'est cette émission de ce voyage
j'ai fait pour moi ce message avec le
monde entier
pourquoi montrer six matches - qu'on
croit avoir perdu on n'a pas perdu ce
mardi à l'amour les gars sont celles de
ckoi problème les voisins etc
donc on a vu une crise d'image d'un vol
entre le mains aujourd'hui c'est le
manque est ce qu'il ya vraiment un
changement assez positif
c'était positif pour ce mois ci le des
régions plus qu'on sait que vous avez
vous des projets tout simplement tout
simplement
je mais je préfère que vous complaisez
dans cette position que je me sentirai
faire avec moi quand je suis pas allé je
ne suis pas certain d'une chose je le
fais moi j'aime bien que vous voyez
regardez mission comprenait le message
que les gps ovi ce qu'on fait et je le
fixais aussi posséder questions de la
presse d'un petit compact interviewés
disent qu'ils sont qui m'avez posé une
question au moins 16 g dans les vitesses
l'on pourra gênant parce que moi je dis
que le paradoxe de cette époque c'est
qu'on n'a plus de connaissances mais
moins de patience et tolérance et simple
du connaissance du moins de patience et
olé
c'est ça le problème on a plus plus
d'experts mais plus de montée
c'est ce que je veux changer votre
voyage et vous dire c'est court ça a été
a bon je ne pouvais pas expliquer ça
vous pourrez vivre partir d'une émission
pour la regarder sur le lait est
exactement ce que moi aussi qu'on
appelle le départ le projet commun des
français et cetera on a proposé à pas
mal de chez votre production va refuser
tout simplement sans qu'on en voit
maintenant il ya tout qui veut qu'ils
devront délicieux et les modes de
production et ses moyens physiques
comme je vous ai expliqué c'est ça pour
moi que je partage réalisation et
marketing la vingtaine et qui est très
important pour moi c'est que si vous
voulez le disait elle sata difficile où
nous arriver pleurais je vais pas vous
dire qu'on est ans il a brisé les justes
jeune attiré notre attention
si tu veux arriver à point mais j'y
arrive pas parce que tu peux faire mon
chien arrive à changer l'argent tu vas
changer l'accord pourra le voir deux
portes qui sont maintenant mais je
profite des autres
pour ma part pour arriver très simple tu
veux devenir réalisateur mais j'espère
par action et tragédie avoir un salaire
le rappel et après tu peux ajouter un
studio de combien et s'étendent au
racing restait d'avenir que tu les avais
qu importe déjà chercher ailleurs
tu as changé
on a pu arriver
visitez cosmos des partis pour ne pas
dire mais on a du mal à passer pour un
départ à votre choix c'est très
important de communiquer la relation
c'est très important
aller vers l'autre et moi que je vous ai
dit j trouviez dans la soluce j'ai pas
légende est toujours là mais ça marche
pas tu peux pas comme ça c'est à nous il
faut il faut que tu fais tu vois j'ai
toujours bien joué il ya pas de maladie
de mon bien pour massy qui n'a pas de
fin d'année seront servis est-ce que je
peux mais n'a pas de mari vient me voir
publier en annexe
vous allez manquer si vous avez déjà
essayé à consulter le premier pas ça
marche ça marche
ses six essais c'est juste c'est juste
c'est juste l'avion moi j -c l'avion si
tu parles est en crédit
objectif moyen de long et au couloir il
est différent mais a tué un dernier
message je vais vous montrer avec moi la
finale c'était l'épisode 4 de
l'exclusivisme on n'est pas à trois
tirages c'est le holà aux couleurs ça
s'est invité l'église au coeur tellement
et le topix a rappelé 60e charles désy
je veux laisser mon
prise après l'épisode 4 à 2 mais moi j
des fois que c'était trop tard le maroc
être yoann va quitter la personne âgée
qui sent qu'ils ont été sauvés mais pour
que tout le monde soit là année je sais
pas mais fait si vous aujourd'hui faites
vous fais pas je vous dis pas de il faut
juste vous riez vous rêvez vous pas voir
l'intérêt général
j'ai couché
j'étais petit et les vocalises situe
tout cas me yasmina système régime est
un truc normal ce sont aux gouvernements
sept autres l'éducation ce soit en
dessous les jeunes ce soit les médias
que ce soit partout on sait qu'on doit
réfléchir
l'intelligent à diriger et à prévenir
que chaque voix juste
sa place à ses principes moi ma nage et
j'y monte à paris et je voulais c'est
pas la main au coucher sous voyage je
suis parti c'est la première fois
l'espace qui vont du voyage ensuite vous
parlez tarde pas si sûr magnifique mais
malheureusement ça comme un autre de mes
racines j'ai la chance que je vous dis
et je joue le jeu 97 cents par jour
il te fais confiance si finalement
laissé passer beaucoup de pays ça existe
les étapes
merci à tous ceux qui ont ainsi cette
deuxième édition des ssii
déshabiller curiosité jouer à tence vous
accordez moi non on devient un jour
j'étais aussi en eux